The amount of craftsmanship and attention to detail that goes into perfecting animated films is in a class of its own
Every tiny detail from Movement to background objects has to be rendered and programmed to add naturally and to stay consistent
Throughout the length of the picture "Is that right?"
It's no wonder that most of these films have received high praise
from critics and Award shows alike and have earned fond memories from Children and adults alike
"Ahhhh, Pah Poy!"   That's why when a mistake makes its way into the final product, fans may never be able to look at that scene again without seeing
the mistake. Here are 10 obvious mistakes we never noticed in our favorite animated movies.
Are you a fan of movies and TV,
And want to stay up to date with our content? Give us a like and hit the subscribe button to stay current with all things
Screen Rant. Also, do you like mobile games as much as we do?
"Umm. I think so.." Boy, have we got some good news for you then.
Stay tuned for some awesome info about an awesome game called War Robots.
And before we start, can you guess this movie from these emojis? Stay tuned for the answer at the end of our video.
"You kind of set off an eternal winter everywhere."
"Everywhere?" " It's okay. You can just unfreeze it."
Frozen: Let It Go, am I right people? Well, that may be what the animators did with this once-you-see-it mistake. In the
mega-hit film from Disney, Elsa runs away from home to the Snowy Mountains and
bursts into the song "Let It Go" as she changes into her ice-queen form for the rest of the movie.
During the number however,
Elsa lets her hair down in a fashion that straight up defies physics as her hair braid passes directly through her arm.
We knew Elsa has some crazy powers, but we didn't know she could influence matter. That is seriously impressive.
"Oh, no! We're crying at school!"
Inside out: you're probably more familiar with the case of Riley's mother and the teleporting glasses
But there's another animation mistake in the oscar-winning picture by Pixar that you may not have noticed.
"Are you kidding me? Out of the gate? This is not happening!" When sadness accidentally causes Riley to cry in class, fans may
have noticed that something else was amiss. On her desk, Riley has a couple of notebooks which somehow end up shuffling around on their own
Throughout the scene. Ironically the color of one of her notebooks is blue which fits nicely with the theme of Sadness.
The Road to Eldorado:
After being stuck at sea, the con artists Tulio and Miguel are finally spared when they spy land in the distance.
Overjoyed that they're not going to die in their tiny boat and the company of their horse, the two men begin
praising the sand, even going as far as kissing it.
It's quickly revealed that there are skulls
littering the beach that they landed on. Yet, in a wide shot that was shown moments before the reveal of skeletons,
there was no indication that there was anything at all on the beach.
What's your point? Dramatic reveal is one thing, but teleporting Skeleton heads would be enough to put most people back on the boat
Kubo and the Two Strings:
a contender at the
2017 Academy Awards, Kubo and the Two Strings dazzled audiences and critics alike with its complex story and characters.
But animation is very much a tricky endeavor.
Especially when it comes to digital
Stop-Motion animation in one instance in the film, Kubo is told to follow the setting sun in order to find the fabled helmet
He needs recover.
There's only one problem: Kubo ends up walking towards the rising sun. The
orientation of the shadows and the sun indicates that the animators may have had a momentary lapse in orientation
But thankfully it didn't stop Kubo from completing his quest.
Pocahontas
Sometimes, animations end up doing the strangest things quite often breaking the rules of logic and physics
That's exactly what happens in Disney's Pocahontas. In the film, Pocahontas and her friend
Nakoma, can be seen approaching the tent holding each other's hands, yet under the moonlight a different
Tale is being told as the two friends shadows are not holding hands. Is this the real story we're supposed to be looking at?
"Please, don't say anything."
Tiny details like this may not seem obvious during the animation process, but once it's out there, the tiniest details always seem
So large, don't they?
Finding Nemo
Marlin thankfully found Nemo in the film, but did you find this animation mistake towards the film's Climax?
Nemo finally gets into the dentist office with the help of the pelican nigel
However the dentist is not exactly happy to find a large bird in his place of work
Quickly trucking nigel out yet on the wall near the window of poster magically disappears and reappears
between shots
your attention may be focused on the bird and the action but one glance to the right and it becomes impossible not to see the
poster between shots "you should expect an increase in body hair
especially on your face, chest, armpit
And..." " Thank you thats enough." Big Hero 6, one of the most memorable things from Big Hero 6 is the character Baymax
"hairy, baby"
But there may be another memorable moment stashed away in your memory
Banks that we're about to drag back into the light.
In the film Hero is confronted by professor callaghan pretty early on Who asks the feature Road adventure "may I?"
"Sure." yet between shots professor callaghan shirts somehow goes from blue to red and then back the blue
It's a quick moment, but as soon as you see it. You can't unsee it
*Lions growl*
The Lion King. The Lion King broke all of our hearts when it came out in
1993 and has continued to do so over the decades, but in an era before digital animation the animators had to painstakingly
Animate by hand it's amazing that the attention to detail is at the level that it is but of course mistakes can still happen
In the film the Hyena Shenzi ends up being slashed in the face by simple leaving deep triple lines cuts across her face
Yet moments later in the movie her wounds are completely gone and not even a scar has been left behind
"What did you say ?"
"Nothing."
"I got him! I got him!"
Despicable me. In the opening scene of the movie
Despicable me a young boy can be seen running past a barricade with a toy plane in his left hand
the Stubborn boy proceeds to then fall off of a wooden piece of scaffolding
And into the fake pyramid which Springs the boy back up to safety
However during this strange turn of events the boy somehow had time to put the plane into his right hand despite being extremely squished inside
that fake pyramid
Monsters Inc. Now what could possibly be scarier than monsters in the closet and under your bed?
*Screams and yells*
Well forgetting where you stashed your evidence due to an animation mistake of course in the film the child known as boo makes her way
into the Monster World Which uterly
Terrified sully in his fit of fear
He tries to flush boos belongings down the toilet after they stuck to the giant blue monster
The toilet begins to back up and sully decides to stash the evidence in Locker 193, but during the next shot
It seems sully actually put everything in locker 190. Dammit sully, pay attention
This is how problems are made. "Well isn't that nice?"
So there you have it folks. Did you notice these mistakes before? Does knowing them ruin your enjoyment of certain scenes now?
Whatever you may think comment below and tell us your favorite animation mistake
*giggles*
Now, do you like mobile gaming? Why not head on over to your app store and take a crack at War robots
War robots is a highly competitive 6V6 multiplayer experience that can be downloaded straight to your mobile device
Joining the ranks of the metal warriors will give you access to some sweet sweet chrome machinery as you fight your way to victory
across a variety of even sweeter map by clicking
Screen rants exclusive link below you'll start up your robotic conquest with 100 golds
100,000 silvers and two guns straight from the Get-go, that's a whole lot of benefit from your favorite YouTube channel
You're welcome by the way or robots embraces improvisation
creativity and admiration while still being really fun and the answer to the movie emoji is ...
"Puss in boots"
Did you get the right answer?
Let us know in the comments below and don't forget to like the video and subscribe to screen rant for more fun videos
Like this one. The fun doesn't stop here as you can head on over to CBR to get even more fun content on the daily
Anyway, thanks for watching